ma vuoi per caso conoscente notizia
questo è un rito dei muri buono però nel
sito salsa verde ma ci tiene a tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo video
sono fa dj oggi doveri che quindi stiamo
su è più visto ragazzi è incredibile che
non siamo passati anni dal mio ultimo
video di happy feet
segnatevi questo momento subito vai con
escape che non so che cos'è che sostano
no aspettate veloce mi jacket è stata
allora devo riuscire ad uscire dal buco
senza una gamba ma se il piede fuori
aspettare che dovrei iniziare perché non
ho capito bene cosa devo fare allora
ragazzi lezioni di senza confavi j così
nascono i bambini in poche parole deve
riuscire a una donna che è impossibile
ma possibile che non riesca a far el il
traguardo cazzo non è difese
e superman
[Musica]
dal primo livello si capisce quanto avrà
senso episodio sicuro andrè abbiamo fa
abbiamo fare io sinceramente ho fame una
bistecca al sangue grazie non così a
sangue dove cazzo si affiderà a nuovi
stadi no [ __ ]
ok come ho detto ha ingoiato 1 prima
diversi ragazzi è che questo vi insegna
che mangiare le persone non è una cosa
buona non sono sicuro ma credo che
questo sia l'esatta consistenza dei
panini del mcdonald più o meno la stessa
cosa secondo me questa macabra cazzo ma
cosa vuol dire ma vuol dire che il
nostro intestino ci sono nel nostro
intestino ci sono le spade che girano la
scienza confavi j schweppes i ragazzi
stiamo per arrivare alla parte bella di
mika si sa non c'è la parte dove ci caga
nel cesso ragazzi adesso cioè tutti
sulle mani per il giorno finale cazzo ma
perfetta ok ok allora abbiamo abbiamo
appurato che la fase finale la più
divertente cli rob smith da quelli che
non faccio lops lincoln è di alla
ragazza possiamo fare perfetto esaltato
oggi è dire garcia fa perché ti sta
inglobando il tuo vabbè lasciamo perdere
vai così miyake che lanciò lo perdoniamo
per stavolta perché poi che a [ __ ] da
secoli che non fa un robin come si deve
mi chiami servizi l'ho visto bruttissimo
anche anche questa
anche questa ci siamo ci siamo dati
quasi mi leggo un libro che mi sembra di
essere accesso solo minchiate salto sì
sì no no perché no che chi ha il suo
paia di lascia prima di 0
mi stupiscono sempre di più se come io
ve lo dico con nuccio accesso entrambi
in messico a perfetto buongiorno lo
tiene su un pochino di podcast per un
amico ottiene anno tiene podcast non
tiene podcast perfetto
ciao legami che io vi giuro passerei le
giornate a farse cagate perché sono
costrette ci chiamassero calvi paga ma
che cazzo succedono non mi incazzo si fa
a schivare una pallottola in un modo più
figo di questo
[Musica]
il ponte chiuso o ragazzi il ponte
chiuso in italiano ma dovremmo saperlo
sapevo ci avrei scommesso qualsiasi cosa
adesso con molta calma indietro mammamia
accetta cazzo o persone che hanno
davanti ma che cosa cazzo si fa attorno
qui sotto ma vaffan come torna a fare i
biscotti mulino bianco piuttosto è
un'impresa impossibile ma ce la posso
fare
rosina è per te perfetto ci sono sono
vivo non ha senso è una casa media un
tequila proporre anzi doppio resto
questo non è tequila non abbatte world
rowing dobbiamo facevano svolto come si
deve perché ci sono i cannoni perché non
c'è uno sguardo con dei cannoni fatemi
capire non è che spara le spade mi
chiama mi chiama buon altro parà anche a
sessuale e anche pesanti porte
cioè io te l'ho detto che ragazzi tu fai
quello che vuoi
porca [ __ ] è una che cazzo successo
ragazzi buon natale a tutti
è una cosa che cazzo succede a unted
minimi che che non è oro bruttissimo
questo qua vista che facendo cagherà
addosso ancora non l'ho giocato ragazzi
non so che cosa sia ma chi se ne fotte
saltiamo allora sinistro non so ma
[ __ ] non l'ho presa ma che cazzo
perché c'è nonno ciak perché so che
l'hanno già cazzo fai ragazzi ve lo dico
oggi faccio i culi perché mi hai
lanciato una chance tron bravo buffa
perché mi è rimasta una festa incastrata
togli tex e anche brutto che posizione
sexy per fatemi capire qual è sentito ok
solo vip sono vivo per miracolo si no
cazzo gettar ma si può essere più idioti
di così come ho fatto a mancare i
ragazzi ma perché è rimasta incastrata
la testa vi sto tizio prima è perché c'è
un casco nella spalla perché si va a fan
culo anno togliti vecchio giorni che c'è
salto ha fatto si può perché ti sei
attaccato al mio culo ma ci si può mai
portare non c'è chi in giro così non è
norma ma neanche i cani
dico sì ma perché non certo ha detto ti
portano in salvo io ok come non detto
cento per cento il prossimo
i ragazzi l'ultimo riuscì a volte hanno
fatto di un prossimo sarà stato chi
cazzo fa con la sinistra
l'ultima volta l'ho fatto in imposti con
sarà stato tipo tre mesi fa e ci sarà un
motivo
fischiati exalto ragazzi ho fatto una
cosa che non riuscirò mai più a fare
vita mia
non vi fate domande rega ma zero proprio
come cazzo vuol dire omen una cosa a
perfetto da mangiare dove lanciare st
palla controllano ciak ragazzi in questo
questo è un documentario su chi ha
problemi di alcolismo
credo che sia un problema più che
evidente ragazzi l'alcol uccidere
imporsi ball pan cerchi odio chi è
questo ragazzi sto tizio allora amico
mio facciamo una bella chiacchierata nei
due siti azzardi a toccarmi
devo riuscire alla partita ma porca
[ __ ]
la bici la bici ha vinto la bce ha vinto
ed è già un traguardo vediamo se riesco
a farmi qualche mischia che il genio che
già ora staccarmi dalla vice non so come
cazzo mi è venuto in mente o cliccato
per sbaglio ma va bene così estrarranno
che cazzo di e devo correre sulle stelle
è una cosa
mio dio ragazzi perché ricordate che il
mondo compagni stelle è un mondo
migliore
ma che cazzo successo noi scendi dalle
stelle dice che disastro sono perfetto
ma non che abbiamo mai più calmi che è
impossibile sto livello dove andare
avanti se si si si si usi un cazzo
ragazzi sto livello assuma come faccia
fare il salto alla fine assurdo cela mio
dio allora vediamo se di riuscire a
farcela ma vediamoli riuscire a fare una
cosa decente
o fai tin tournament cos'è sta roba
ragazzi così chi è quel tizio ragazzi
che cazzo fa voi siete 72 figli ovvero
dico siete assolutamente dei gran figli
fermi che c'è qualcuno che le cerca qui
te la sei cercata zucca
va bè ragazzi direi di provare questo è
il mio livello
in conclusione perché da secoli che non
faccio ai miei livelli vissuto vj
ragazzi non fatemelo fare fatemelo fare
perché fa bella perché gestito fa bella
per farvi jay chou fa vj allora per me
proprio una cosa non ci sarei mai
arrivato
blitz ei the killer ma perché non c'è
chi si è dato all'alcol ultimamente non
me n'ero accorto ti giuro non me n'ero
accorto e non c'è che via via fate
vivere in pace [ __ ] no [ __ ]
qui vibra vivrà per sempre con le sue
bottiglie ed è che hai da dire sul mio
casco che fa schifo brutto fra nicchia
che lottano i [ __ ] notato può
aspirare perfetto luke lo sapevo che la
ragazzina mib usa rotolamento e super
efficace che schifo è è una cosa non
sono morto ragazzi sono morto a un metro
dalla fine porca [ __ ] papa ragazzi
ieri che posso concludere qui perché
tipo mila per la connessione mi sta
partendo
non so perché dopo poche gioco ai primi
parte la connessione sta cosa la devo
ancora capire questo tipo nonno ciak che
mi versa largo sul mot e non lo so
comunque ragazzi york compiuto fino
episodio come al solito se il video mi è
piaciuto lasciato un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come non i
video tratte nella descrizione serio se
non iscritti iscrivetevi non ci
rivediamo il prossimo vito belle ragazze